alors dominique farrugia comme vous êtes
chef on va vous faire une interview
cire-pompes
[Applaudissements]
connard
intermédiaire pompe alors vous êtes
intelligent cultivé
charmant drôle craquant généreux comment
vivez-vous dominique farrugia toutes ses
qualités au jour le jour
quand elle se commet sa taille haussière
pour vraiment
suisse a normalement un peu un peu
parfois a parfois mieux que d'autres
jours ce que c'est vrai que là je suis
bronzé saremi en tresse elle va beaucoup
mieux là on voit bien les yeux bleus
c'est magnifique très très beau zoom
serge est ce que vous êtes conscient de
votre charisme hors du commun non mais
maintenant que vous me faites penser
peut-être un peu plus oui oui pourquoi
c'est un rêve de bosser avec vous pour
tous pareils à cause de mes la réussite
de titoff des gens comme ça ça fait
rêver ouais enfin contributeurs en plus
il ya le cas des oliviers je donnerai
plein fouet par les agents des bois là
je commence à vraiment me croire
vous tenez d'où cette classe dans le
comportement dans l'habillement façon de
vous tailler votre barre de la chasse à
courre à deux matchs à sa famille
célèbre pour ses charmes si
ce plan professionnel j'ai effectué un
parcours on peut dire sans faute à
carrière impeccable c'est qu'un élu 1
comment faites-vous dominique farrugia
pour avoir toujours raison
j'ai jamais tort ouais ouais
petit à petit vous êtes devenu
parfaitement indispensable au paysage
audiovisuel français
comment ferait tous ensemble où il
cherchait vraiment à [ __ ] la pause
comment je cite je suis jeune je ne sais
pas ce que je dois pas par vous qui
pourrait vraiment prendre ma place c'est
vous
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'ina l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux